this and I I was doing some reporting on
this in Cleveland there are a lot of
young kids who are Bernie supporters and
delegates who understand electoral
reality and institutional reality and
and are not actually and they they feel
angry that the media has portrayed them
as nihilist who want to blow up the
party and are going to vote for Trump
and I and I think you know yes there
were a lot of rabble rousers in the hall
if you're gonna pick the rowdiest people
like the rowdiest people are naturally
going to be inclined to go to the
convention and make noise but I think
the vast majority of Sanders supporters
sort of understand the stakes here and
have been sort of wrongly but once
Hillary got the nomination shouldn't
they have shut the up you know I
need at what point and what are they
saying about that and also she said some
great things that I think he said they
would have cheered she said she were not
singing his speech in some ways she has
a way of you giving lip service to these
progressive issues we want to know what
has she done on the ground for poor and
working people that's the question I
took you know I'm gonna do a howl
pelicans long a frank answer that but if
Bellary Clinton really you think has
done nothing for poor no let me say
nothing I said she has not done what
people say in terms of her being this
great champion for the poor people
that's a lot with this loves only two
items on the menu no we got three we got
Jill Stein hold up a sec we got more got
food we got Gary the third one okay yeah
we only got order wait we'll have any
chance of becoming every moment it looks
that way but I swear to ya audience and
I don't
so you think Jill Stein is gonna be
president look me in the eye and tell me
that we shall see
but it's gonna be tough yeah it's gonna
be tough but part of it is this nobody
you got to draw a line in the sand we're
not we're not raise the question you
about David Duke and and Donald Trump in
your own mind you had the law draw a
line in this I draw a line in the sand
now energy it's not dumping all because
all that that just shows under certain
conditions you wouldn't make a choice
between two fold if I refuse let me let
me as long as we're doing analogous let
me give you in an hour okay let's work
with you're on a train station yeah
right here in LA you want to go to San
Francisco there's a wedding up there you
got to get there there's one train
that's goes in San Francisco but it's a
little slower than the one you want
there's one other train leaving but it's
not going to San Francisco it's going to
hell
it's not going to help it's going to San
Diego which is lovely city but it's me
but it's not where you want to go you
want to go to San Francisco
the only other train is going in the
opposite direction you get on the train
that's going in the direction you want
to go but slower or do you go to San
Diego
let me ask the question can I just
answer that I love I love this analogy
though but listen to get it this way
back to brother match point the Clinton
train Wall Street security surveillance
militaristic not good that not going in
the same direction I'm going it's just
better than the neo-fascist like Trump
that just fit you you really think
Hillary Clinton is on the same spectrum
as a neo-fascist no I said milk passes
like Trump right but you think she's in
ok the neoliberal hey lip move okay I'm
not calling her Neil fathom let us
clarify that ok but but but I do believe
neoliberalism is a disaster let me I do
believe that when here comes the poor
people when it comes to people in other
party with u.s. foreign policy military
I didn't know absolutely they asked the
people in Libya about that ok ask the
people in the West Bank about that ok
but once again Donald Trump is insane he
is insane a local man is dating crazy
nothing to hit over his head what are
your fashion owners not in Santa he
reaches hatred in